John you've been on the run for five
days now what's going on where is this
going no idea where it's going to uh say
I do know that the Prime Minister and
the prime minister's statement yesterday
could be equally reversed um you know if
I think that he himself is Marcus if she
can throw away the constitution of the
country and become dictator without the
world catching on that was John McAfee
at 4 49 p.m. Belize time Thursday
November 15th for the past six months
I've been interviewing him and now wired
is publishing my exclusive 13 chapter
ebook investigation into his life what
follows here is a compilation of my most
recent conversations with him the Java
the gang depression is to suppress the
gang as well yet they showed up to my
heart right well is the other example
ugly businessman in belmopan whose house
was bright surrounded and they opened
fire and all I just saw like specters of
people to do enough research to
understand this point so they look like
when I say well you know given what I
see I I think there's a high chance or
something you know and vibrate like I
was beaten only to death you know still
quite a while when they broke his job
when they did among other things yeah
right yeah I think that's a pretty
severe blow to break a man's job of
course um so so so no I don't intend to
put myself through that this is a fact
and I did I did no less than him by you
know he never he didn't speak how much
against they got rid he didn't do much
someone didn't like even turned in an
anonymous tip and then the next thing
you know he's in the hospital or
knowledge it's happening this is where
we live this is this country if people
can understand that then I will talk to
them I think I'm living in America and
acting the way I'm acting that I'm a
madman mean everybody's reporting that
mcafee says his
friends have been arrested long Jesus
Christ is an easy thing for people to
check you mean the Intendant charge
everybody cash I in fact way mine they
did let my chair my my security guards
white girl right oh you heard that right
yeah I heard that I effect i sold out of
the baby she had the one year old all
right the and they let the taxi driver
go finally huh ok well can you charge a
taxi driver for me to take about
it so we were there is what they're
searching for things as far as other
they're stretching the gun laws ok
there's just inventing shift with to
charge people with under the gun laws as
to my situation anybody who will bother
to a Google police the changes of the
Constitution would take over of the BTR
telephone company and the subsequent
refusal to return it to its rightful
owners by blending in the army and
anyone who's willing to google the
abuses of the gang super communitarian
police will have no problem
understanding my reluctance to turn
myself in and I need to get off the
phone now sir ok John thank you talk to
you later